I'm talking about the people what do you
mean by clean people what do you mean by
clean people are you excluding that
whose dirty the poor fellow I read
showers an invigorating way to start the
day
or are they a smooth relaxing way to cap
off your night oh I don't know we're
gonna figure it out though morning
showers versus night showers it's
debatable
I'm Kelsey and I shower at night and I
showered this morning I take showers in
the morning because I'm not a crazy
person and I take showers at night I'm
for night showers and I'm in favor of
morning showers I'm in support of
morning show I'm here for the night
shower what's better in the morning I'm
just waking up oh I'm tired let me hop
in that shower let me get fresh let me
be alert to let me wake up morning
showers wake you up in the morning it's
a great way to start your day by getting
clean the thing hey ready for a new one
have you heard of coffee it does the
same exact thing my opponent might say
yes well I can wake up with something
like coffee or drugs we don't need that
did you just call me a drug I sweat
profusely when I sleep I'm a very sweaty
man as a result I am disgusting in the
morning and a shower
very quickly solves this problem you're
gonna go to bed you're gonna sweat
you're gonna drool no one looks pretty
when they sleep I do it's called
sleeping beauty have you read it at the
book that was a fairy tale yeah but it's
also story of my life take a shower
you're fresh you're ready for whatever
the day has to throw at you got a
meeting boom fresh you're not like oh
I'm all sweaty because I was laying in
bed all night I don't get that how
sweaty do you get at night how hot is
your room shower solves everything
shower doesn't solve what sexism
I care about the American people I care
about your emotional state you go
through a long hard day it's rough
you're tired you have a cup of tea you
have a glass eating but you have a hot
cup of tea and then you get in a nice
hot shower going throughout the day you
get dirty we're lifting these heavy
lights we're working on set we get
sweaty all that pollution is on your
skin it's black day you're sad and so
you want to go and just wash it all off
the max yourself I also think that
showering at night is better for the
environment most people in the morning
they take really hot showers for a
longer time because they're tired and
they're trying to use it to wake up I
don't you shower Shelly cold showers
wake you want more empowers leave relax
that's why hot showers water's coming on
you have a weird faucet it's a great one
good no it's no it's just nice lip as a
woman we're told that our value is only
based on physical appearance and so
forcing me to wake up you know an hour
earlier so I shaved my legs in the
morning because men tell you that you
have to look a certain way there's men
in quotation marks
Jory's if I could just roll out of bed
and [ __ ] put on a t-shirt and go to
work yeah that would be nice but I kind
of suck and put on my armor god dammit I
gotta do all of this [ __ ] to look this
good in a male-driven society people
gotta take me seriously
in conclusion I wake up in the morning I
take a shower and I smell good for the
rest of the day we need to take a shower
at night you're not sleeping in your own
sweat and pollution all night and it's
better for your skin it's better for
Humanity you're acting like I take a
dump in my bed I don't know I would say
that I would love to live in a world
where me and everybody else was capable
of taking a night shower but it's just
not realistic ultimately this debate is
one that's really hard to apply to a
macro level morning showers are best for
men and if a woman move on and take her
shower the night before I get that I
agree I'm proud of us Chris think we
learned something here today
okay are we having a smell test right
now